what makes being married worth it wild
sex
[Applause]
sorry it's kind of a flip answer but I
couldn't resist what makes it worthwhile
so I noticed in my clinical practice
that couples who stayed together had to
spend about 90 minutes a week in
Intimate contact with one another and
also just talking for 90 minutes about
their lives about the domestic economy
about the kids about the practicalities
of life and at the same time they wove a
rope that was their joint story and
that's something to have in your life
you know to have someone who you're
moving forward with that you can
communicate with honestly who you can
rely on in times of trouble and to call
you out on your stupidity thank God for
that